Speaker 1: in a completely cowardly, pathetic,
disgusting but yeah, absolutely predictable
move.
House Republican leaders are coming out in
opposition to even investigating what happened
on January 6th with the Trump riots in Washington,
D.C..
Democrats and normal people want to investigate
January 6th because it was an absolute disgrace.
It was an outrageous, tragic moment in American
history.
And there are almost endless avenues of investigation
that should be pursued.
Who all participated, who was responsible,
who instigated.
What are the full explanations for delays
in getting National Guard and more police
to the Capitol?
Who knew what and when the day of I could
go on and on.
But there are endless avenues of questions
which I would love to see answered.
And yet Republicans sent out a letter.
Republican leaders sent out a letter to Republican
members of Congress yesterday trying to convince
them to vote against a bipartisan proposal
to launch an investigation which in structure
could be similar to the 9/11 Commission.
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy, a disgusting
person, came out against the bipartisan deal,
saying the scope of the investigation is too
narrow.
Now, this is really is the it's not shrewd
because shrewd almost has like a positive
connotation, maybe cynical, you might think.
Wow, Kevin McCarthy thinks the investigation
is too narrow.
So clearly, McCarthy wants to investigate
more things about January six.
That sounds good, right?
Wrong.
Republicans say in their letter that to really
investigate what happened on January 6th,
you need to investigate things that are completely
unrelated, like when Steve Scalise got shot
at baseball practice in twenty seventeen,
the letter that they wrote says, quote, This
commission cannot investigate the political
violence leading up to and following the attack
on the 6th, including the June twenty seventeen
shooting at the Republican congressional baseball
practice and the deadly attack on Capitol
Police on April two.
Twenty twenty one.
The report is due too late to properly educate
and advise on securing the Capitol complex,
and there is no prohibition against indefinite
extensions.
Not said there is that the January six riders
were all Trump supporters inspired by Trump
and maybe to some degree by right wing media.
The shooting of Steve Scalise in twenty seventeen
really has nothing to do with this.
Now, on the Senate side, Mitch McConnell,
who is the Senate minority leader, says that
Republicans are undecided on whether to go
ahead with the commission, but they're open
to hearing arguments.
Some Republicans have already expressed support
for the commission.
For example, Texas Republican Senator John
Cornyn said, quote, I think we need to do
something to identify the problems.
I mean, shame on us if we can't address it.
Now, I asked on Twitter yesterday, why would
anyone be opposed to even investigating the
January 6th riots?
And I received some really interesting responses.
Here's a representative sample.
One viewer telling me because they are scared
the truth will be told about things they don't
want anyone to know about.
Another follower of mine on Twitter says they
I think they mean they are connected to those
who are responsible and therefore are complicit.
And a very comprehensive answer giving for
reasons why Republicans are opposed to the
investigation, a, it will incriminate their
dear leader, Donald Trump.
B, it will incriminate their voters and supporters.
See, it will incriminate their fellow Republican
Congress members and it will incriminate themselves.
Let's hope that this panel is formed and that
the investigation happens.
Now, one last thing in the defense of some
Republicans, some Republicans do want to do
this.
And I think that's a good thing.
Right?
Like, that's something.
And of course, this should be done a little
bit later in the show.
I'll tell you about Man of the People and
government transparency advocate Tucker Carlson,
who is completely against this investigation.
Really transparent.
Right, guys?
This is why populism and faux populism can
be such a pernicious thing.
That's a little bit later.